[Música]
el estrés canceroso primero que nada
pensemos cuántos de nosotros hemos
estado estudiando trabajando o tan solo
saliendo adelante en la adversidad de la
vida
pero cuántos de nosotros nos hemos
preguntado qué es lo que verdaderamente
me ayuda a salir de mis problemas
antes de continuar les quiero platicar
mi pequeña historia
hace algunos años midiendo
aproximadamente unos 65 y siendo un
alumno de excelencia académica
pesaba más de 90 kilos siendo así que
estaba en obesidad mórbida
por la misma recibía burlas y exclusión
pero me decía a mí mismo sabe si van eso
no vale la pena y seguí adelante un día
voy con la doctora por unas manchas
negras en el cuerpo
y ese mismo día se me diagnóstica
previamente
y mi vida ya no es la misma de este es
el momento pero ha aprendido a salir
adelante y continuar con la misma
y la doctora me explicó que como en
familia directa ya habían diabéticos mis
probabilidades serán del 75 por ciento
pero revisando mis conductas e historial
encontró que la vida que llevaba a tan
corta edad estaba llena de constante y
elevado estrés pues el estrés es un
impulso de sobrevivencia es algo que nos
sacan apuros
pero si no lo sabemos limitar controlar
y usar para bien nos va a terminar
afectando en la salud en este caso a mí
fue el páncreas
les hice la primera pregunta y la vamos
a retomar
todos lo todos siempre estamos buscando
la manera de salir adelante de sacar la
chamba de tener un mejor empleo un mejor
puesto de lograr los proyectos de decir
dos simples palabras lo logré
ese es nuestro objetivo en la vida salir
adelante
con la segunda amigos me es no se me
vayan a espantar puesto que es el estrés
el estrés diario lo hemos representado
como algo malo que el primer momento que
los sintamos dos para matar pero no es
así un estrés que se sabe limitar
controlar y usar para bien
nos sirve para salir adelante
un ejemplo simple piensa en una lista de
tareas bien atiborraba que no le caben
ni una coma
piensen que la tienen que hacer para el
día de hoy
cómo se siente
se siente pesado
y sientes que lo tengo que sacarlo
entonces te vas a ministrar de cierta
manera en la que debes de decir
wow lo logré
no me
pues esa es una forma en la que se
manifiesta un buen estrés
no hablo de un estrés acá es un estrés
acá que te dice vamos a hacerlo de tal
manera que vamos a salir de la mejor
forma
quiero hablarles sobre el carro si en el
momento de la obra
me van a preguntar cómo se relaciona
esto con lo de la lista de tareas
aguanto el momento mira el carro si fue
reconocido en japón hasta 1987 y puede
ser una muerte oficial dictada por un
juez
interpretado traducir el español puede
ser como muerte por exceso de trabajo
a de que el trabajador por ser servicial
y eficaz a la empresa da hasta la vida
por misma como dato curioso para que él
pues lo puede determinar el trabajador
tuvo que haber hecho 100 horas extra en
el mes antes de su muerte y 80 horas
extra en dos meses en los seis meses
antes de su muerte es algo increíble
trabajar de 16 a 20 horas si no es que
24 no dormir nada
de que del espacio para ti
esto se relaciona con el estresarse de
más
porque es porque de ser perfecto
perfecta
y de lo mejor te descuidas
retomando la lista de tareas
dices ok
pues quiero que salga increíblemente
perfecto ya sé que a veces es un la snes
es una de las necesidades básicas de
mantener un empleo pero de verdad debes
de sacrificar tu vida por eso
de verdad vas arriesgarte de verdad
vas a hacerlo
tenemos que aprendernos a poner límites
porque
y un límite nos salva la vida nos dice
hasta aquí llegaste por eso hizo una
jornada laboral de 8 horas
por eso dices
con eso ya en tiempo para mí me doy mi
tiempo para no sé al es fácil quieres
ver la televisión jugar un videojuego ir
a ver un partido dentro deporte favorito
y darte un tiempo para ti porque te lo
mereces
las cosas no siempre van a ser perfectas
somos humanos cometemos errores
lo importante de nuestra vida es
saberlos corregir y decir
si pude lo logré
como diferenciar cuando un estrés normal
se convierte en un estrés canceroso
primero que nada lo voy a explicar que
es un cáncer
exacto una malformación generada a
partir de células que se reprodujeron
mal el que no sirve un cáncer pues que
yo he investigado de nada positivo son
los causa angustia y dolor ya los que
nos rodean no sólo nos afecta a nosotros
todos nuestros círculos sale perdiendo
un estrés normal como ya he dicho te
ayuda a seguir adelante a lograr tus
objetivos un estrés canceroso
un ejemplo estás en la computadora
viéndola 30 minutos tu lista de
pendientes a un lado estás pensando ok
voy a hacer este después aquel y estoy
haciendo este momento que estoy haciendo
tienes la pantalla durante 30 minutos en
blanco el word sin escribir nada
mejor aprovechamos el tiempo si estás
atiborrado y no puedes con tu cabeza es
30 un poco no pasa nada por 5 o 10
minutos
sal a caminar
platicó un poco despeja t puesto que la
creatividad
necesita que estés tranquilo
esto lo puedo decir cómo es nuestra
jaula
y nuestra cadena sin fin
no la podemos ver porque es una pecera
invisible una pecera que es muy difícil
de ver
sólo logrando verla la podemos romper no
si no sabemos que existe vamos a charlar
para poder saber que existe refleja se
refleja en tu salud
si estás viviendo de estrés canceroso
vas a poder tener probablemente lo más
seguro las ojeras por los más abiertos
el cabello se te esté empezando pero de
la nada y no es genética qué está
pasando ahí
y les quiero dar un ejemplo reciente y
personal que tuve inicios de año
pues inicio la oportunidad en la beca un
nuevo semestre y pues nuevas
oportunidades
yo dije va porque no no pierdo nada
y empecé a aplicar estaba haciendo mis
proyectos mis lecturas mis análisis
ensayos etcétera etcétera etcétera
pero llega un punto en el que me sobre
el saturn porque no pensé en eso
yo digo
y yo recomiendo tener un abogado del
en la cabeza me refiero a pensar
mal a decir voy a hacer maldades no me
refiero a decir
qué voy a hacer si me pasa esto si por
la piedra que está en el jardín me
tropiezo y no puedo asistir el examen
porque voy al hospital
no hay que ser tan extremos como este
caso mejor decir ok
y si no llego a tiempo la junta
y sí
y no me aprueban
y si los veo no muy convencidos como los
voy a convencer cuál es mi plan b c d e
efe
cuál es mi plan
de segunda mano
esto lo relaciono con el dicho familiar
que tenemos el no ya lo tienes por
delante que te cuesta buscar el si se
trata de decir bueno mucho y lo poco
pierdo mucho ganó poco está igual puedo
no puedo
porque está bien decir no puedo no somos
omnipotentes
no tenemos mil brazos no podemos estar
de un lugar a otro a cada tiempo no
tenemos tiempo infinito
somos humanos no somos perfectos y eso
es lo que nos hace perfectos
vive en tu vida de cada momento pues no
sabe si el día de mañana no vas a
despertar no sabes si algo va a pasar
todo junto no nos deja salir adelante
administre manos de tal manera en la que
digamos
estoy disfrutando mi vida
esto se relaciona con el estoicismo el
control de nosotros mismos de nuestras
acciones y sus consecuencias se trata de
hacernos completamente responsables de
lo que hacemos y de lo que decimos
diciendo y controlando nuestra propia
destrucción o liberación
me refiero a que cada quien tiene el
control de si hay dos maneras de boris
la manera no digna y la manera digna
en ambas siempre vamos a trabajar para
alguien más
pero en esta manera puedes decir
disfrute de mi vida hice todo lo que
quise cuando lo quise como lo quise no
me arrepiento de nada mientras que de
esta manera nunca disfrutaste tu vida
y maurice está diciendo hubiera hecho
esto hubiera hecho aquello
voy a resumir lo que les recomiendo para
convertir el estrés canceroso
medita un poco de decir que dice en la
mañana que hice en la tarde y que voy a
hacer una noche estoy administrando bien
mi tiempo
estoy haciendo las cosas bien no les
puedo dar una fórmula general para el
ministro a su tiempo pues cada quien es
único y tiene un estilo diferente
experimenta y crea el tuyo y como
segunda opción proponte en las cosas de
manera menos radical puesto que si no se
nos cumple nuestro objetivo
podemos llegar al que reformados y no
querer seguir adelante
recuerda que lo más importante eres tú
los que te rodean y lo demás como el
dinero y el trabajo van después sin ti
no hay una vida por vivir vive tu vida y
disfrútala muchísimas gracias